j'ouvre tout de suite notre second débat
consacré à la Cour pénale internationale
25 ans après sa création comment la CPI
enquête-t-elle à la fois sur les
attaques terroristes du ramas et sur les
victimes civiles de l'armée israélienne
à Gaza quels sont les moyens des
magistrats des policiers français qui
sont spécialisés dans ces procédures de
euh crime contre l'humanité ou de
génocide justement ces termes crimes de
guerre crime contre l'humanité comment
qualifier les horreurs commises depuis 5
semaines au proche- Orient avant d'en
débattre retour sur ces actes qui
intéressent la justice pénale
internationale avec Flora sauvage depuis
le 7 octobre date des attaques du has en
Israël le bureau du procureur de la Cour
pénale internationale a reçu plusieurs
plaintes dénonçant tour à tour les
crimes du Hamas et ce d'Israël jeudi
dernier un dossier a été soumis au
procureur au nom d'une centaine
d'organisations de la société civile
réclamant une enquête pour génnoocide à
Gaza c'est plus simplement une opération
militaire avec ses abus qui peuvent être
des crimes de guerre
on a déterminé que il y avait ça
commenca à beaucoup ressembler à un acte
de génocide créé en 2002 pour juger les
pires atrocités commises dans le monde
la Cour pénale internationale est
composée de 18 juges et siège à l'E au
Pays-Bas elle ne peut juger que quatre
catégories d'infraction considéré comme
les plus graves les crimes contre
l'humanité les génocides les crimes de
guerre et les crime d'agression je crois
qu'il y a deux crimes principaux qui
seraient pertinents en l'espèce c'est le
crime de guerre donc qui correspond à
toute violation de ce qu'on appelle le
droit humanitaire le droit humanitaire
c'est le droit qui s'applique en
situation de conflit armé donc le fait
de s'en prendre à des civils de manière
volontaire à des cibles civiles ou le
crime contre l'humanité qui en gros
correspondent à des atteintes très
graves au droits les plus fondamentaux
des personnes et qui a l'avantage entre
guillemets par rapport au au crimes de
guerre de pouvoir être qualifié même en
dehors d'une situation de conflit armé
reste qu'Israël n'a pas ratifié le
traité de la Cour pénale internationale
et n'a pour conséquent pas l'obligation
de coopérer en un peu plus d'un mois
près de 11000 personnes ont été tuées à
Gaza selon le Hamas près de 1200
israéliens sont décédés et 240 personnes
sont toujours retenues en
otage comment juger les crimes pris au
proch Orient en débat avec aéliia Devos
bonsoironsir bienvenue vous êtes
magistrate ancienne directrice du pôle
le crime contre l'humanité du tribunal
judiciaire de de Paris et vous publié
crime contre l'humanité le combat d'une
procureur c'est aux éditions Kalman Levi
B Nabli bonsoir et bienvenue vous êtes
professeur de droit à lupec Paris 12
consultant international au cabinet
lisias partner et vous publiez relations
internationales droit théorie et
pratique c'est aux éditions pédon
Jean-Pierre Perin bonsoir bienvenue à
vous aussi vous êtes journaliste
écrivain auteur de ce livre la mort et
ma servante lettre à un ami assassiné
qui porte sur la Syrie la période
2005-23 chez fayar j'accueille également
en duplexe le colonel Éric emau ancien
chef de l'Office central de lut contre
les crimes contre l'humanité les
génocides et les crimes de guerre
bienvenue à vous je cite votre livre la
traque et mon métier un officier sur les
traces des criminels de guerre aux
éditions plomb et laticia crupa
littitoraliste politique est resté à mes
côtés question très générale peut-être
trop générale pour commencer Aurélia
deos est-ce que vous pensez qu'on jugera
un jour les crimes commis en ce moment
au Proche Orient devant une Cour pénale
internationale alors je je pense que je
ne sais pas surtout bien sûr il y a des
pistes il y a la Cour pénale
internationale bien évidemment on sait
que le bureau du procureur de la Cour
pénale internationale enquête déjà hein
bien avant les événements récents depuis
2021 il enquête sur d'éventuels crimes
commis depuis juin 2014 donc peut-être
que les enquêtes progresseront et
peut-être que des responsables de de
crime pourrait être l'objet de mandat
d'arrêt d'abord et puis ensuite être
jugé mais il y a aussi les justices
nationales bien sûr les justices
nationales israéliennes euh qui euh qui
peuvent aussi mener des enquêtes et et
poursuivre il y a les justices
limitrophes qui peuvent être concernées
avec des des personnes qui se réfugient
euh dans ces pays ou des ou des victimes
d'autres pays qui entraînent la
compétence et puis il y a toutes ces
justices nationales dont nous faisons
partie qui applique la compétence
universelle et qui peuvent avoir affaire
à ces crimes on sait déjà que le Paul
crime contre l'humanité a ouvert des
enquêtes concernant notamment les
victime française ouais Jean-Pierre per
on peut peut-être expliquer cette cette
notion de compétence universelle
pourquoi elle est très importante et
c'est c'est bien de le dire dès le début
de ce débat oui alors moi moi je je
m'aventurerai pas sur le terrain
juridique je suis plus plus un homme de
terrain que donc je préférerais
simplement parler moi de mon expérience
si vous voulez chaque fois que j'ai
enquêté et j'ai enquêté pendant une
trentaine d'années ou sur différents
crimes de guerre sur des génocides et
cetera je je pense que j'ai labouré la
mer personnellement je n'ai jamais
jamais jamais eu vu la moindre de mes
enquêtes intéressées quiconque au niveau
je veux dire soit au niveau judiciaire
soit au niveau ONG soit au niveau
international pourquoi ah je je ne sais
pas c'est pas à moi de poser la question
moi je me contente de par exemple j'ai
enquêté longuement sur le massacre de
Hamas euh en
1982 commis par euh alors on est où là
on est en pardon excuse-moi Syrie qui
est une ville complètement encerclée et
complètement anéantie et et mes
estimations et pas seulement les miennes
moi les miennes sont plutôt inférieures
à celles de la moyenne c'est de 20000
morts 20000 morts nous avons le
responsable de ces 20000 morts qui
étaient le frère de haz elAssad donc le
l'oncle de Bachar elAssad qui a vécu en
France pendant des années qui a été
choyé qui a eu la Légion d'Honneur j'ai
tout raconté ce qui avait été fait jour
par jour à h il n'a jamais eu le moindre
souci jusqu'à ce qu'on se pche sur son
patrimoine immobilier donc c'est un
exemple mais je pourrais en citer bien
d'autres en Israël j'ai enquêté à Gaza
également j'ai relaté dans les détails
comment une une famille avait été
complètement exterminé par l'armée
israélienne famille palestinienne jamais
eu non plus de conséquence j'ai parlé du
phosphor blanc jamais eu je pense que
j'ai vraiment labouré la mer simplement
on y reviendra en détail je vous donne
la parole tout de suite un mot sur cette
notion de compétence universelle
peut-être à vous la compétence
universelle elle est extraordinaire
c'est-à-dire qu'on va être compétent
pour juger des auteurs qui sont de
nationalité étrangère qui ont commis des
faits à l'étranger sur des victimes
étrangères avec l'unique lien de
rattachement avec la France qui ait soit
la présence sur le territoire soit sa
résidence habituelle et donc c'est vrai
que le lien est très ténu et il nous
fait sortir de nos compétences
habituelles d'accord c'est ça la
compétence univelle permet à des
magistrats ou à des policiers français
d'quter sur sur ces crimes B nabl vous
avez signé une tribune dans dans l'OPS
titré Gaza cimetière du droit
international pourquoi dites-vous
ça tout simplement parce que un certain
nombre de crimes internationaux sont
commis encore actuellement dans ce
conflit et qu'il y a une incapacité à la
fois de ce qu'on appelle la communauté
internationale et y compris des
belligérant à respecter le droit
international de la guerre le droit
international humanitaire qui les oblige
à priori à respecter précisément un
certain nombre d'obligations notamment
ce consistant à ne pas commettre
certains actes qui relèv de crimes
crimes internationaux et le problème
c'est précisément aussi plus largement
euh c'est ce c'est l'objet de de la
tribune c'est que ceux qui ont pensé
finalement cette avancée historique du
droit international parce que ce qu'on
vient de rappeler rapidement à savoir
l'existence d'une Cour pénale
internationale un droit international
humanitaire et un droit international
pénal tout ça est relativement nouveau
et c'est l'aboutissement d'une réflexion
à l'échelle internationale et qui a
consisté à instiller euh ben une
philosophie à la fois libérale humaniste
reconnaissant l'universalité des droits
de l'homme euh et tout cela est aussi
l'héritage de la fin de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale et cet héritage là d'une
certaine manière on en est on n'est pas
à la hauteur on n'est pas à la hauteur
parce qu'on arrive pas à respecter
précisément ce qui devait être
consensuel et euh y compris sur le plan
discursif y compris dans nos positions
diplomatiques et là je me permets de
souligner précisément un parallèle
extrêmement saisissant entre ce qui
s'est
passé dans pour la guerre en Ukraine et
ce qui se passe actuellement en
Palestine dans le cas ukrainien la Cour
pénale internationale est exemplaire
elle est exemplaire parce que quelques
jours quelques semaines après
l'agression l'invasion de l'Ukraine par
la Russie et bien le procureur de la
Cour pén International s'est saisi de
cette affaire il s'est déplacé sur le
territoire ukrainien pour prendre acte
et enquêter sur les crimes des soldats
russes sur le territoire ukrainien et
cette dextérité cette rapidité
d'exécution est exemplaire parce que là
ça nous permet de croire dans les
principes et les consacrés par le Statut
de Rome et et
com le procureur c'est alors il a pas pu
rentrer dans Gaza mais il est allé
jusqu'à Rafa a pris la parole le
procureur de la Cour pénale
internationale donc il y a quand même
cette volonté de marquer la présence de
la Cour pénale internationale oui mais
ça été rappelé euh en fait les crimes en
question notamment commis par l'armée
israélienne ne date pas de ce conflit
c'est la 5e opération de cette nature en
deux décennies à peu près avec à peu
près les mêmes types de crimes
premièrement et deuxièmement et
deuxièmement le l'autre problème encore
une fois c'est autant côté occidental un
consensus une unanimité pour soutenir la
Cour pénale internationale dans son son
activisme et son volontarisme en Ukraine
et heureusement autant là pour le coup
non seulement il y a silence mais on ne
condamne pas les crimes commis donc
c'est ce deux poids de mesure qui
affaiblit finalement finalement cette
héritage et notre notre conviction
suivant lequel il y aurait une
universalité des droits de l'homme la
Cour pénale internationale on va
rappeler créer je vous donne la parole
tout de suite hein le siège est à la ha
fondé en 98 par le Statut de Rome
ratifié par 123 états il y a l' ité
palestinienne considè que c'est un état
mais pas Israël voilà information que je
donne en passant vou prendre la parole
oui je voulais juste rajouter quelque
chose lors de la du précédent d'un des
précédents israéliens attaque
israélienne sur Gaza bon 2008 2009 il y
a eu après cette cette frappe ces
frappes cette invasion même du
territoire de Gaza par l'armée
israélienne il y a eu le rapport du juge
sud-africain est un rapport très très
éteayé qui a qui a
h statué qui a défini un certain nombre
de de crimes de guerre et qui est très
très bien instruit et qui n'a donné
absolument aucun résultat à ma
connaissance et ce j'ai oublié le nom du
juge sud-africain mais c'était un
rapport que que j'ai que j'ai consulté
que je suis servi dans mes dans mes dans
mes articles mais jamais eu aucune
conséquence donc c'est comme s'il avait
travaillé lui aussi comme s'il avait
laboré également la merou alors je je on
va être le plus pédagogue possible hein
parce que même moi j'étais j'avais des
doutes je veux bien comprendre vous
étiez directrice du Pô crime contre
l'humanité du tribunal judiciaire de
Paris vos enquêtes elles elles étaient
indépendantes de celles de la Cour
pénale internationale dont on est en
train de parler ça ça pouvait se
recouper expliquez-nous oui elles sont
absolument indépendantes il s'agit
vraiment d'appliquer le droit français
devant des juridictions françaises donc
c'est complètement indépendant de ce que
peuvent faire les juridictions
internationales ça ne veut pas dire
qu'il peut pas y avoir de coopération je
DIRIS même qu'il y a plus qu'une
coopération une vraie complémentarité
euh c'est-à-dire que euh la justice
internationale c'est pas seulement la
CPI c'est pas seulement la justice
nationale c'est tout ça et c'est un
patchwork de juridiction qui vont
constituer une sorte de filet très serré
parce que
l'objectif de la compétence universelle
des juridictions en plus de la CPI c'est
qu'on ne puisse pas où que ce soit
trouver refuge à un moment donné et
échapper à la justice c'est ça le sens
de cette compétence universelle et donc
ce qu'on fait en France dans le pôle
crime contre l'humanité c'est vraiment
de la justice franco-française en
quelque sorte mais avec la coopération
internationale et vous donnez mission à
des policiers de traquer ces cri je vous
donne la parole ces criminels de de
guerre ça peut durer pendant des années
je me tourne vers vous Éric
est-ce que vous avez vous aussi je vais
reprendre l'expression de Jean-Pierre
Perin le le sentiment de la bourée la
mer ou au contraire vous vous dites on a
eu quand même des
résultats alors oui on a quand même des
résultats il suffit de regarder les
différents procès qui ont eu lieu ces
dernières anné années en ce qui concerne
les Rwandais notamment et puis récemment
le Libérien là on a euh on va dire un
certain nombre de résultats aussi du
côté de la République démocratique du
Congo avec euh Angé lambala donc oui il
y a des résultats alors après c'est vrai
que on est au sein de l'office euh
submergé de dossier on va pas on va pas
le nier hein puisque rien que pour le
Rwanda par exemple on a à peu près un
petit peu plus d'une trentaine de
dossiers enfin on avait à l'époque où où
j'étais à la tête de l'office un peu
plus d'une trentaine de dossiers et si
on couvre la Syrie on est sur les mêmes
volumes et bon il faut savoir qu'à
partir du moment où comme l'a expliqué
madame Devos à partir du moment où on a
un individu qui est sur notre territoire
il peut faire l'objet il doit faire
l'objet d'une enquête qui est
effectivement dirigeantée par l'Office
central de lutte contre les crimes
contre l'humanité donc évidment ça
couvre toute la planète donc on part du
Sri Lanka à
l'Afghanistan l'Afrique l'Ukraine
maintenant et à chaque fois qu'un qu'un
conflit émerge autour de cette planète
et ben évidemment on a les trois
catégories de personnes qui peuvent
faire l'objet de noquête en France
savoir victimes françaises puisque là et
ça va être le cas pour le conflit entre
le Hamas et Israël auteur français
puisqu'on peut très bien avoir des
individus qui sont par exemple impliqués
dans des milices et qui se rendre
coupable de CRIM de crimes de guerre ou
de CRIM contre l'umanité et puis enfin
on a selon la règle de la compétence
uncielle qui a été rappelé et pour
éviter que notre pays soit un refuge
pour bourreau parce que c'est quand même
ça véritablement l'objet du de cette
règle de la compéence universelle et
bien on peut enquêter contre ces
individus merci je vous donne la parole
un peu plus tard évidemment Éric eto ça
veut dire Aurélia deos que par exemple
les les les Français binationaux qui ont
été victimes des attaque terroriste du
Hamas la la justice française peut ou
peut-être d'ailleurs c'est déjà saisi de
d'une enquête sur ces les conditions de
leur mort absolument elle le peut et
elle l'a déjà fait puisque plusieurs
enquêtes sont ouvertes effectivement sur
les personnes qui sont disparues et
celles qui ont été tuées et qui sont
binationales euh ce que je voulais
peut-être ajouter par rapport à ce qui a
été dit tout à l'heure et notamment le
massacre de Hama qui avait été évoqué je
crois que ça soulève une question
juridique qu'il faut un petit peu
éclaircir c'est que on a beaucoup tardé
pas seulement en France mais un peu
partout à se mettre en de faire ça n'est
qu'en 2010 qu'on va adapter le Statut de
Rome qui crée la Cour pénale
internationale et ça n'est donc qu'en
2010 qu'on va pouvoir poursuivre en
France sous la qualification de crime de
guerre et pas avant et donc dans le
massacre de Hama c'est quand même très
très intéressant parce que nous n'avions
pas en 1982 ni les crimes de guerre ni
les crimes contre l'humanité dans notre
ordonnance av pas l'arsenal juridique
donc on ne peut les qualifier que de
crime de droit com des assassinats des
tentatives d'assassinat et donc on se
retrouvait face à une situation de
prescription puisque l'apport très
important de ces qualifications c'est
que les crimes contre l'humanité sont
imprescriptibles et ça va nous permettre
de faire autre chose mais donc
effectivement la bour et la mer j'aime
beaucoup cette expression parce que
c'est aussi que vous rappelez mais
effectivement ce son c'est aussi le
sentiment que peuvent avoir les
enquêteurs comme les magistrats dans ce
type de dossier mais comme le ditem pas
parce qu'on peut pas tout qu'on ne peut
rien et donc des choses se passent jeis
je la parole après mais voulez
intervenir de choses alors autant les
les victimes
francoisraéliennes pourront demander
justice à la fois devant la justice
française mais aussi via la saisine de
la Cour pénale internationale mais
autant il y a un pendant le pendant
c'est que les soldats franco-israéliens
aujourd'hui à Gaza pourrait très bien
être poursuivi pour euh crime de guerre
s'il était Ave vérit qu'ils étaient
impliqués dans de tels crimes eu égard à
certaines photos qu'il diffusent dans
les réseaux sociaux il devrait réfléchir
avant de de communiquer de cette manière
car il y aurait par là une
responsabilité pénale qui pourrait être
engagée de de leur côté donc ça de preu
pendant un procès ce qui est posté sur
ser ça serait insuffisant s'il montre
juste un missile c'est ce que moi j'ai
j'ai vu par contre j'ai vu des
détentions arbitraires où ils étaient fi
de de de ces actes là pour le coup c'est
beaucoup plus grave et beaucoup plus
problématique donc il y a cette
dimension là qui avait qui était déjà
apparu dans d'autres opérations cette
question de la binationalité à la fois
pour les victimes mais aussi du côté des
des bourreaux autre aspect sur lequel
vous étiez passé vous aviez passé à
savoir la relation entre les deux
belligérant par rapport à la Cour pénale
internationale donc Israël vous avez
raison n'est pas état parti oui
précisément pour échapper à toute
responsabilité pénale devant la
Cour pénale internationale mais pas en
tant qu'État naturellement parce que
c'est la spécificité de la CPI c'est
qu'elle poursuit des individus des
dirigeants politiqu c'est pas parce que
Israël n'a pas adhéré au Statut de Rome
que on pourra pas poursuivre des c'est
autre aspect mais vous avez raison en
dépit du fait qu'Israël ne soit pas
parti au statut ces dirigeants
pourraient théoriquement être poursuivi
alors encore plus théoriquement soit
via la cour le conseil de de sécurité
qui pourrait très bien théoriquement
voter une résolution qui amènerait la
Cour Pénale à poursuivre les dirigeants
israéliens ou via une initiative
volontariste du du procureur et côté
palestinien ce qui est très intéressant
c'est que vous avez rappelé qu' l'État
de Palestine qui n'existe pas en tant
qu'État souverain mais ça ça ne marche
pas comme ça en fait quand vous voulez
être reconnu comme un état c'est chacun
des sujets du droit international comme
on dit c'est-à-dire les autres États et
organisation internationale qui vous
reconnaissent ou pas donc il y a à peu
près 130 états aujourd'hui qui
reconnaissent la Palestine euh dont
l'assemblée générale des Nations Unies
et cetera mais la France par exemple ne
reconnaît pas l'État de Palestine la
Cour Pénale international reconnaît un
statut à la Palestine qui lui permet
aujourd'hui de poursuivre un certain
nombre de d'actions alors dans ce débat
on va continuer de de de se concentrer à
la fois d'ailleurs sur les les actes
terroristes du Hamas comment on peut les
qualifier et comment on peut les juger
et puis aussi éventuellement sur la
capacité d'Israël est-ce que Israël
outrepasse son droit à riposter c'est
l'une des questions centrales de ce
débat mais je voudrais qu'on faceasse un
point un peu de de sémantique grâce à
Mathias Arz qui va nous rejoindre tout
de suite sur ce plateau parce que
rebonsoir Mathias c'est vrai qu'on on
entend voilà et on utilise nous-même sur
ce plateau un certain nombre de de
termes CRIM de guerre crime contre
l'humanité génocide ils ont des
définition juridique oui tous les
politiques français sans exception ont
employé l'un de ces trois termes de
depuis un peu plus d'un mois Thomas a
raison c'est moins sûr on parle de
termees juridiques précis vous venez de
le dire avec des définitions également
précis puisque ce sont les articles 6 7
et 8 du Statut de Rome qui n'est ni plus
ni moins que le texte fondateur de la
Cour pénale internationale signé en
1998 certains de ces termes vous vous en
doutez sont antérieurs par exemple le
génocide dont la première définition
remonte à 1944 cette notion juridique je
le rappelle pour être qualifié doit
conjuguer deux éléments un un élément
psychologique l'intention euh de
détruire en tout ou en partie un groupe
national ethnique racial ou religieux
comme tel et un élément matériel tel que
le meurtre de membres du groupe des
atteintes graves à l'intégrité physique
ou mentale la soumission intentionnelles
à des conditions d'existence des mesures
visantes à entraver les naissances et
enfin le transfert forcé d'enfants un
exemple en 2004 le Tribunal pénal
international pour l'exyoslavie qualifie
de génocide le massacre de 8000
bosniaques à frbrinica alors maintenant
on va se concentrer sur le l'expression
le terme crime contre l'humanité alors
comme pour le génocide le crime contre
l'humanité peut-être commis en période
de paix et n'est d'ailleurs pas
nécessairement lié à un conflit armé là
encore pour être caractérisé plusieurs
éléments doivent entrer en ligne de
compte un élément matériel meurtre
extermination torture réduction en
esclavage la liste est longue et elle
apparaît ici un élément contextuel
l'acte doit avoir doit avoir été commis
dans le cadre d'une attaque généralisée
ou systématique lancé contre toute
population civile un dernier élément une
dimension psychologique les crimes
contre l'humanité impliquent soit une
violence à grande échelle soit une forme
de violence méthodique à noter que sont
exclus les actes de violence aléatoire
accidentelle ou isolé là aussi un
dernier exemple le régime d'apartè en
Afrique du Sud est aujourd'hui considéré
comme un crime contre l'humanité h et
puis on va parler évidemment on a fait
le génocide le crime contre l'umanité
maintenant focus sur le crime de guerre
oui à l'inverse du génocide et des CRIM
contre l'humanité les crimes de guerre
ont toujours lieu lors d'un conflit armé
international ou non d'ailleurs la liste
est extrêmement longue plus de 53 cas
entrent sous cette dénomination ils sont
divisés en cinq grandes catégories ce
commis contre des personnes nécessitant
une protection particulière ce commis
contre les pourvoyeurs d'une aide
humanitaire ou les participants aux
opérations de maintien de la paix contre
les biens et d'autres droits les
méthodes de guerre interdite et enfin
les moyens de guerre interdits un
dernier exemple en mars 2020 21 l'exchef
de guerre congolais Bosco
entaganda a été condamné à 30 ans de
prison ferme pour crime de guerre il lui
été reproché l'utilisation de gaz ou
d'armes généralement interdites qui
peuvent causer des souffrances inutiles
merci beaucoup Mathias pour pour toutes
ces informations Aurélia Devos on n' pas
volontairement employé le le le terme
d'acte de terrorisme est-ce que ça
rentre dans ces catégories ou est-ce que
un acte terroriste en l'occurrence les
actes terroristes du Hamas peuvent être
considérés aussi comme comme crime de
guerre ou crime contre l'humanité alors
les actes de terrorisme c'est pas du
droit international c'est c'est du droit
commun défin par les États qui vont
avoir chacun leur définition et leurs
périmètres de l'acte de
terrorisme ça n'est pas exclusif
c'està-dire que il peut y avoir deux cas
de figure c'est-à-dire que un groupe à
caractère terroriste commet des actes de
nature terroriste et peut en même temps
ou par ailleurs commettre des actes qui
vont être qualifiés de CRIM contre
l'humanité par exemple de crime de
guerre s'il est dans le cadre d'un
conflit armé ou de crime de génocide on
peut penser à daesh pour les crimes
contre les yésidis qui ont été qualifiés
de crimes de génocide on voit bien que
c'est un groupe à caractère terroriste
qui commet aussi des crimes de génocide
et puis il peut y avoir une
qualification double pour des faits
identique mais là il va falloir qu'on
démontre et qu'on enquête très précis
prisément et c'est ça qui est compliqué
sur l'intention coupable on a en même
temps envie de terroriser d'intimider
donc commet un acte de terrorisme mais
on a aussi envie par exemple de
s'attaquer de manière systématique et
généralisée à la population civile ça
peut entraîner un cumul entre l'acte de
terrorisme et le crime contre l'humanité
donc tout cela évidemment c'est du cas
par cas et de l'étude de tous ces
éléments que vous avez très justement
rappelé ouis on parlait du du procureur
de la Cour pénale internationale donc
qui s'est rendu à ce point de passage de
de Rafa entre l'Égypte et la bande de
Gaza je vous propose de de l'écouter sur
les actes terroristes du ramas
justement la prise de Tage constitue une
violation grave des Convention de Genève
et un délis spécifique en vertu du
Statut de
Rome je demande la libération immédiate
de tous les otages pris en Israël et
leur retour en toute sécurité auprès de
leur
famille euh B on a on a entendu certains
politiques notamment en France mais pas
seulement qui parlerit d'acte de
résistance pour qualifier les les
attaques du Hamas le le 7 octobre ils
ont tort au regard du du droit
international je pense qu'ils sont
partis de l'idée que Gaza était sous
occupation militaire israélienne ce qui
est reconnu en droit international mais
en fait le raisonnement qu'on qu'on
applique à Israël en matière de légitime
défense s'applique aussi pour ceux qui
revendiquerai la résistance face à
l'oppression je veux dire par là que
même si vous réagissez face à une
situation d'occupation bah vous n'avez
ça ne justifie pas pour autant des
crimes de guerre des crimes contre
l'humanité voir un génocide vous voyez
donc c'est le même raisonnement
autrement dit concrètement le Hamas ne
saurait justifier ce qu'il a commis au
nom de l'occupation subie par Gaza ça ne
marche pas c'est n'est pas fondé en
droit international ouais Jean-Pierre
Perin euh israël veut éradiquer le Hamas
c'est le le les termes qui ont été
employés à plusieurs reprises par
Benjamin netanahou ou ou d'autres auut
responsable du du pays est-ce qu'on peut
imaginer que l'État hébreu peut-être que
c'est totalement de la politique ou de
la justice fiction mais juge certains
dirigeants du ramas dans un procès un
jour ou est-ce que la logique c'est pas
plutôt d'essayer de les voilà de en
premièrement le tu les uns après les
autres oui premièrement le Hamas n'est
pas qu'à Gaza il est aussi en C Jordanie
et je
juste rappeler que un certain nombre de
dirigeants du Hamas de s Jordanie ont
été arrêtés emprisonnés jugés en
particulier euh certains maires de de de
de communes qui avaient voté pour des
responsables du Hamas donc oui je pense
que le effectivement la priorité je
pense pour Israël c'est certainement
d'éliminer les les responsables du Hamas
on ne peut pas exclure non plus que
certains soient soit jugé je voudrais
revenir sur un point vous avez raison
quand de dire qu'il y a eu des avancées
formidables en terme de
de d'arrestation et de poursuite contre
contre des des personnes ayant commis
euh des des crimes de guerre ou des
crime de génocide et crime contre
l'humanité mais nous avons l'Allemagne
par exemple qui est un exemple
formidable puisque il y a quelques
années s'est tenu le procès d'un d'un
colonel d'un de la sécurité militaire du
régime de Bachar el-Assad qui a été
condamné à la perpétuité pour euh une
série de meurtres commis dans les
prisons du régime notamment je souviens
de 4000 actes de torture donc voilà je
je pense qu' la justice allemande s'est
saisie et a pu enquêter arrêter et jug
oui parce que la le colonel en question
le colonel anoir si ma mémoire est bonne
avait été arrêté dans un avait été
reconnu dans un supermarché par une de
ces victimes qui s'en était sorti
question il est en prison à parpétuité
en Allemagne oui absolument oui oui il
est pas imaginable qu'il soit renvoyé en
Syrie où il serait immédiatement libéré
effectivement donc je effectivement il y
a des avancées qui sont notables si je
j'avais souligné le le fait
de le massacre gros massacre de Hamas
c'est parce que le responsable lui dans
les il y a encore quelques années
plastronnait librement à Paris où il
pouvait même circuler avec un
giryrophare et cetera donc qui avait la
Légion d'honneur qu'on lui avait pas
retiré c'est ça qui était choquant c'est
on l'impression quand même qu'il y a
deux poids de mesure si vous voulez que
les pays qui
sont
vainqueurs sont mieux traités que les
pays qui sont vaincu je m'explique on
voit beaucoup de dirigeants de pays
africains pays du tiersmonde bon par
excellence mais on en voit beaucoup
moins de dirigeants de responsables de
pays
disons qui sont des pays disons
démocratique par exemple le le cas de
MSF à kundou en Afghanistan frappe sur
un
hôpital de géré par MSF disons MSF avait
prévenu à maintre reprise les autorités
américaines que que cet hôpital existait
qu'il fallait surtout pas l'épargner bon
là il y a une frappe épouvantable il y a
eu de plusieurs dizaines de morts mais
jamais il y a eu jamais un responsable
américain a étéé pour jamais jamais
jamais je sais bien que les États-Unis
non plus ne sont pas
signataires je je vais je vais vous
poser la même question à vous et à Éric
em sur justement est-ce que vous avez
parfois le sentiment alors il y a la
question des moyens on va pas redire
encore une fois la bouré la bouré la mer
mais c'est vrai que vous êtes pas très
nombreux à enquêter qu'il y a des
dossiers qui sont partout sur la planète
on l'a compris mais est-ce que vous avez
parfois le sentiment effectivement d'une
je reprends un peu votre votre
démonstration d'une justice un peu à
deux vitesses comment vous vous
l'abordez ça Eric
ah déjà nous euh lorsqu'on reçoit un
soit transmis du parquet en l'occurrence
du du pôle crime contre l'humité on n
pas d'état d'AM hein à partir de là on
déroule une enquête qui est souvent
d'ailleurs dans un premier temps au plan
national pour vérifier que l'individu
soit bien présent sur notre territoire
et puis puis ensuite l'enquête après son
arrestation se projette sur le le pays
en question alors c'est là où
effectivement il peut y avoir des
différences de par la façon dont le pays
va nous accueillir pour
être donc soit on envoie en fait si si
le le pardon je vous interromps si vous
si vous étiez saisi excusez-moi de vous
interrompre erricemr si vous étiez saisi
par exemple d'une enquête concernant les
les crimes qui sont commis au
ProcheOrient aujourd'hui euh
comment ça pourrait se passer est-ce que
la la police la justice israélienne
pourrait coopérer avec vous ou
pas c'est ça tout
l'enjeu de de ce qui va se passer dans
les les mois et les années à venir
est-ce que effectivement on va avoir la
capacité à partir du moment où on a reçu
le soit transmis du parquet l'enquête et
cetera d'aller vérifier sur place que
les conditions dans lesquelles une
victime française a été ass ciné ou ou
un auteur comme l'a expliqué l'a
expliqué comment dire un intervenant sur
votre plateau à partir du momentù on
aurait un franco-israélien qui se
rendrait responsable dans le cadre de
son de ses activités militaires de crime
de guerre oui ça va être compliqué c'est
c'est c'est indéniable mais on a quand
même des moyens puisqu'on travaille
comme l' expliqué r Devos on travaille
tous ensemble alors à l'échelle
européenne et à l'échelle internationale
dans une galaxie de structure qui
coopère en permanence donc ça veut dire
euh que on on échange beaucoup avec des
ONG on échange beaucoup avec les
organisations internationales avec
Europol euro juste on on monte des
équipes communes d'enquête c'est-à-dire
ce que l'on ne peut pas ce que l'on ne
pourrait peut-être pas avoir parce que
c'est la France qui va demander on peut
peut-être l'obtenir d'une autre manière
parce que un mécanisme nusien va pouvoir
le récupérer ou parce que l'Allemagne
puisqu'on a donné l'exemple de
l'Allemagne tout à l'heure et on a
travaillé en équipe commune d'enquête
avec les Allemands sur tous les dossiers
syriens donc on peut les obtenir de
cette manière là donc en fait si vous
voulez c'est difficile de répondre de
manière brute de décoffrage on sait
qu'il y a des pays qui coopèrent pas ça
c'est sûr mais il est évident qu'après
derrière s'ils font l'objet s'ils
reçoivent une commission roire
internationale ils vont l'accepter ou la
refuser s'il la refuse forcément ça
montrera que ils sont pas très
coopératifs évidemment et la question se
pose d'autant plus qu'il y a un
collectif de d'avocats des centaines
d'avocats qui ont saisi justement la
Cour pénale internationale à la fois il
souhait une enquête qui puisse couvrir à
la fois les crimes perpétrés le 7
octobre par le Hamas mais aussi
d'éventuels crimes de guerre israélien à
Gaza je vous propose d'écûter l'un de
ses avocats maître Gilles dev vere nous
on est là d'abord pour faire le travail
d'avocat vis-à-vis de la cour vis-à-vis
du procureur et de lui dire qu'on a vu
ce qui se passait et que ça justifie la
plainte pour génocide mais on est
également là pour les Palestiniens pour
leur dire vous avez maintenant une armée
d'avocats il y a 300 avocats à travers
le monde qu'on a ri en 10 jours c'estàd
qu'on peut en avoir 3000 et quoi qu'il
arrive la cause des Palestiniens n sera
entendue devant les tous les tribunaux
tribunaux internationaux ou les
tribunaux nationaux hia deos la la
question à laquelle on va tenter de
répondre maintenant c'est effectivement
la la capacité à juger d'éventuels
crimes de guerre commis par l'armée
israélienne ou même est-ce qu'un
Benyamin netanahou pourrait se retrouver
devant un
tribunal un jour ou l'autre est-ce que
je reprends un peu ce que ce que vous
nous disiez Jean-Pierre Perrin est-ce
que c'est réaliste imag ça alors c'est
pas irréaliste de de l'imaginer euh la
difficulté quand même par rapport à
l'Ukraine puisqu'on en parlait tout à
l'heure c'est que sauferreur pour
l'instant le procureur de la Cour pénale
internationale n'a pas eu accès au lieu
c'est très différent parce que l'Ukraine
a ouvert son territoire dans les limites
qui était qui était possible euh donc
les conditions d'enquête étaient bien
différentes en réalité hein donc bien
sûr qu'on peut pas émettre un mandat
d'arrêt sur des vidéos qui sont postées
sur des éléments qui sont recueillis à
droite à gauche sur des euh des articles
de presse ou même des propos recueillis
ça et là il faut quand même enquêter et
et tant mieux je dirais que la Cour
pénale internationale n'émette pas des
mandats d'arrêt euh parce que justement
il y a quelques é temp Jud et ça c'est
important par rapport à la justice à
deux vitesses c'est quand même très
intéressant euh de se poser la question
il y a une vraie différence à mon sens
entre la Cour pénale internationale et
les juridictions nationales que que nous
pouvons engager c'est que le la Cour
pénale internationale on comprend bien
ne peut pas embrasser toutes les
situations ni toutes les responsabilités
dans les crime de masse euh dans dans
son périmètre de compétence donc elle
fait oui mais si elle ne s'attaque que
au entre guillemets petit pays eu pays
les moins développés et à partir du
moment où on fait des choix
inévitablement on s'expose aux critiques
ce qui est très différent avec une
juridiction nationale comme le disait é
em des plaintes sont déposées ou des
informations sont sont arrivent on ouvre
des enquêtes donc on fait pas vraiment
de choix donc on voit bien que quand
même cette justice à de vitesse on peut
moins on peut moins en parler pour les
juridiction nationale très très vite
parce que je vis donner la parole à très
bien juste il y a effectivement ce ce
problème de justice à à deux vitesses
entre grande puissance et petite
puissance mais en vérité il y a pire de
mon point de vue en fait même le le le
clivage entre régime autoritaire ou État
autoritaire État démocratique bah il se
vérifie pas on a donc des États
démocratiques des États-Unis jusqu'à
Israël qui ne joue pas le jeu de la
justice internationale et ça aussi c'est
extrêmement troublant et ça affaiblit le
système international dans la mesure où
on se dit finalement voici des régimes
qui se disent euh comme étant des états
de droit démocratiques et qui en réalité
dès lors que leurs intérêts particuliers
sont en jeu ne jouent plus le jeu de la
justice international et de l'État de
droit et ça ça affaiblit tout le système
tout le système parce que les autres euh
précisément les régimes autoritaires bah
finalement se disent bah tout se vaut
hein et puis vos discours en vérité sont
factices et ne sont que des instruments
de puissance comme des ça se retourne
contre eux contre les états
démocratiques exactement c'est en fait
de mon point de vue c'est là où le
baabet c'est c'est peut-être le plus
problématique de l'invasion de l'IRAC
par les États-Unis jusqu'à aujourd'hui
les crimes de guerre israéliens à Gaza
au-delà des jeux de puissance en fait
c'est la question démocratique qui me
pose vraiment problème parce qu'on a
l'impression que sur la scène
internationale être une démocratie B ça
ça ne veut plus dire grand-chose on
n'est pas exemplaire y compris dans le
notre rapport au droit et dans notre
rapport et notre capacité à respecter
l'État de droit alors il y a quand même
des des procédures on on l'a dit et et
létitien on va faire un zoom sur une
procédure qui vise l'État d'Israël alors
c'est pas la Cour pénale internationale
c'est une autre institution
internationale exactement c'est on en a
pas parlé la cour international de
justice qui est un organe onusien elle a
démarré une procédure qui vise à statuer
Thomas sur la légalité de la présence
israélienne en 6isjordanie 56 ans après
qu'elle ait démarrée donc vous voyez le
temps judiciaire n'est pas le temps
politique et alors tenez-vous bien la
décision de la Cour pourrait intervenir
en 2024 l'année prochaine l'année
prochaine peut-être alors qu'existera on
le souhaite tous une résolution
politique parce qu'on sait que sera
politique cette résolution tous les
États qui sont autour de la table pour
l'instant potentiel des négociations le
disent donc elle viendra percuté
d'accord donc pourrait y avoir une voilà
le temps judiciaire qui rattraperait le
temps politique en quelque sorte cette
procédure j'aimerais en savoir plus elle
fait l'objet quoi de dissenstion c'est
ça oui déjà benah je vais
recontextualiser he la saisine de la
Cour internationale de Justice découle
d'une résolution de l'Assemblée générale
des Nations unies le 30 décembre 2022
par 87 états avec 53 trois abstentions
et 26 votes contre et vous avez raison
Thomas il y a déjà de vif débat sur la
légitimité d'une décision de justice sur
la question
israélienne par exemple certains états
comme le Royaume-Uni contestent purement
et simplement la légitimité de la Cour
internationale de justice sur cette
question il considère même qu'un avis
juridique serait en contradiction et là
ça nous intéresse avec les accords
d'Oslo et certaines résolutions de l'ONU
alors vous l'avez évoqué ce processus
judiciaire pourrait compliquer la
situation ou ou l'éventuelle situation
de déblocage politique c'estoui c'est
inéluctable puisque quel que soit le
temps de la justice si la justice
imaginons politique fiction intervient
avant la résolution politique du conflit
vous comprenez bien qu'elle va interagir
avec les tractations les les belligérant
chacun y voyant bien sûr midi à sa porte
et et aura forcément des conséquences
sur le processus politique je vous
rappelle encore une fois que tout le
monde pour l'instant est pour cette
solution politique de deux états état
israélien État palestinien donc vous
nous dites quoi la justice devrait
intervenir après la la la la la
résolution politique du conflit c'est ça
oui oui elle devrait intervenir après
pour laisser la résolution du conflit
oui mais on lui reproche par ailleurs de
de mettre trop de temps donc c'est c'est
peu par ça mettra trop temps et alors
même si si elle met beaucoup de temps
imaginez Thomas que de toute façon elle
rentrera en percussion elle percutera le
processus politique parce que il faudra
un temps long pour qu'il y ait une une
Concorde internationale sur cette
situation qui est explosive depuis plus
de 56 ans et imaginons une décision de
justice internationale qui re réalimente
le brasier finalement et
relance le bourbier ouais bon j'entends
votre argument moi j'ai j'ai plutôt
l'impression que on a on attend trop
longtemps les décisions de de justice
internationale sur ces sur ces crimes de
guerre non mais surtout en vérité plutôt
que de distinguer voir d'opposer entre
le droit la justice d'un côté et le
politique de l'autre dans ce type de
contentieux on veut bien que ça
participe oui non bien sûr mais surtout
ça participe du même processus et les
Palestiniens en vérité l'ont très bien
compris l'Autorité palestinienne en quoi
elle se distingue du Hamas elle se
distingue du Hamas dans la mesure où
elle a elle a opté pour la non violence
et la voie diplom que ça s'est traduit
très concrètement par son adhésion au
statut de la CPI et sa volonté d'adhérer
aussi à l'U et à dire non à la
résolution du conflit par la voie
militaire donc et et tout cela signifie
quoi signifie tout simplement que pour
arriver à une solution politique
l'autorité palestinenne compte également
sur des décisions de justice parce
qu'elle considère que finalement le
droit international participe de ses
intérêts euh politiques mais Israël n'en
veut pas et à contrarion on est on est
forcé de constater que les Israéliens
n'adhèrent pas au S du Rome euh et ne
coopère pas lorsqu'il y a des procédures
nationales judiciaires euh et que par
conséquent la logique du rapport de
force classique des relations
internationales dominent donc là c'est
c'est fondamental en vérité c'est c'est
l'une des raisons pour lesquelles
finalement ce conflit également mobilise
la communauté internationale parce que
c'est c'est ce qui le structure qui est
en jeu le R de la de la puissance de la
force d'un côté et du droit de l'autre
dernier mot le temps affiler beaucoup
trop vite il nous reste moins de 2
minutes Auréa Devau cette Cour
internationale de justice qui dépend
donc de l'ONU elle vient quoi elle vient
concurrencer la Cour pénale
internationale elle est elle est là en
parallèle elle
est on'est pas du tout sur le même
registre la Cour pénale internationale
c'est une juridiction criminelle hein
donc on est vraiment sur l'application
du droit pénal la Cour internationale de
justice elle vient dire le droit
international de relation entre les
États donc on est on est sur des
registres qui sont vraiment totalement
différents on c'est qu'on juge un état
d'un côté et de l'autre
des voilà ça veut pas dire que ce que
dit la Cour internationale de justice du
statut par exemple de tel ou tel
territoire de tel ou tel état ne va pas
donner des éléments concrets qui vont
pouvoir être utilisés dans une procédure
criminelle exemple puisqu'on parle du du
temps judiciaire Éric je termine avec
vous est-ce que vous pouvez nous
rappeler la la de vise de l'Office
central de lutte contre les les crimes
contre
l'humanité ben merci d'en d'en faire
mention oui c'est or fogit stadus ça
veut dire le temps passe mais la justice
demeure donc vous mettez vous mettez du
temps il faut il faut qu'on accepte ça
pour enquêter le
temps comment dire meilleur ami et notre
pire ennemi meilleur ami parce que
effectivement dans le temps on arrive à
à recueillir les preuves les témoignages
euh et
puis de de quelqu quelqu ordre ce soit
pardon et notre pire ennemi bah parce
qu'il faut aller très très vite pour
justement saisir toutes ces preuves sur
le terrain et c'est ce qui se passe en
ce moment puisque je suis sûr que tout
le monde est en train de travailler sur
sur
C théâtre de guerre pardon merci
beaucoup merci à tous je vais rappeler
les rapidement les les titres de vos
livres Olia de vos euh crime contre
l'humanité le combat d'une procureur
c'est chez Kalman Levy lit relations
internationales droit théorie et
pratique aux éditions pédon Jean-Pierre
Perin on a choisi parce que vous avez
publié d'autres livres depuis mais celui
qui était le plus en rapport on va dire
avec la thématique la mort et ma
servante lettre à un ami assassiné aux
éditions faayard et Erric emra la traque
et mon métier un officier sur les traces
des criminels de guerre publiés aux
éditions plomb merci encore à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat je vous dis
à bientôt sur sur publicb Sénat notez
que demain l'invité de la matinaleinvité
deoriane mansinist r François patria le
président du groupe euh Renaissance RDPI
ici au Sénat belle soirée à toutes et à
tous